[Musica]
avevo quasi 12 anni quando un giorno mio
padre e mia madre portarono me e mia
sorella gemella florinda in un campo di
atletica leggera ed è lì ho cominciato a
correre per non smettere finché ne avevo
o almeno finché il mio corpo nei tendini
miei muscoli hanno detto stop
nei miei vent'anni di agonismo corso
oltre 50.000 km o come ogni maratoneta
per darvi un'idea le coste del nostro
paese sono lunghe 7.500 km è come se ci
avessi corso sopra per quasi sette volte
in questo correre senza fermarsi c'è
stata la mia prima vita una vita piena
di emozioni
ricordo il giuramento per la prima volta
che indossavo la maglia azzurra
giuro dirottare con ogni energia fisica
e morale per la maglia azzurra che il
simbolo sportivo della mia patria
ricordo la prima maratona il primo
infortunio il primo titolo italiano
ecco tutti questi momenti questi ricordi
sono stati tenuti insieme da una cosa
una sola cosa la passione la passione
quella pura quella che che non fa
calcoli che ti permette di andare o di
provare andare un pochino oltre
conoscono bene la fatica gli atleti ogni
atleta lo porta dentro la parola
l'etimologia della parola atleta che
vuol dire lotta competizione sfida la
lotta con te stesso per cercare di
migliorarti di provare a spostare un po
il limite che una parola bellissima il
limite limite è qualcosa che si può
raggiungere si può spostare con la
dedizione il lavoro la tenacia la
fiducia credendo in te stesso e questo
lo sport lo insegna ci sono dei momenti
dove in allenamento ti senti sfinito
svuotato di energie e non sai dove
trovare quella forza per poter andare
avanti ecco è magicamente
non si sa come l'atleta riesce ad
estrarre quell'energia quella scintilla
che ti permette di andare avanti ancora
un metro ancora un metro è stato il
manta nella merita sportiva quando ero
stanca mettevo le gambe una dopo l'altra
e pensavo ancora un metro ancora un
metro ancora un metro è un po come il
mantra del grande campione alex zanardi
come lui ce ne sono pochi
a chi gli chiedeva ma qual è il successo
dei tuoi trionfi e lui rispondeva mi
dico in certi momenti quando sono
stanchissimo svuotati o gli avversari
sul collo dai alex resisti ancora cinque
secondi solo 5 secondi che vuoi che
siano 5 secondi
ecco quei cinque secondi possono fare la
differenza
vale nello sport vale nella vita
e così è stato per me ne ripetermi
ancora un metro quando sentivo che le
energie si andavano piano piano svanendo
sano evaporando cercavo di tenere ancora
un metro
vi ho portato una foto per parlare della
mia storia sportiva in realtà poi sono
due momenti diversi
questa foto è la mia ultima gara con la
maglia azzurra campionati mondiali ad
osaka avevo 37 anni un po tanti già nel
mondo dello sport agonistico e mi ero
riuscito a conquistare questa gara in
primavera ci tenevo tantissimo a finire
bene la mia lunga carriera
quel giorno qualcosa non andò bene
dopo 20 km praticamente le mie gambe
erano ferme vedete la foto io sono
arrivata quasi ciondolante al traguardo
gli occhi chiusi
il viso sofferente dopo 20 km immaginate
che io mi sono sentita come un semaforo
che devi ripartire si è bloccato la
macchina non parte più e avevo ancora 22
chilometri da percorrere
mi ricordo quell'asfalto infuocato mi
ricordo la fatica mi ricordo la piena
coscienza che avevo di aver fallito il
mio sogno il mio obiettivo e nonostante
questo ho cercato di trovare e l'atleta
in questo riesce a farlo dentro di me le
energie per portare avanti quello che
era il mio ultimo viaggio con la maglia
azzurra
fortunatamente riuscì a arrivare vedete
la foto e vedete anche la foto finale
accompagnata da da due assistenti che mi
hanno aiutato a uscire fuori dal campo
era comunque un campionato mondiale e
portavo punti per la mia squadra
arrivando quinta grazie anche alla
prestazione delle altre i miei compagni
di viaggio questo è lo sport
la cosa bellissima di quando si perde
bellissima e che si pensa quando perdi
pensi cosa ho sbagliato cosa c'è che non
andava
rivedi la tua gara come in un film la
sconfitta in segna tantissimo e per
questo che diventa molto fertile
ogni atleta sulla linea di partenza
accetta di poter perdere fa parte del
gioco e che ha portato un'altra foto una
foto più facile la prima edizione della
maratona di milano siamo a dicembre nel
2000 21 anni fa e quella gara è quei
perfetti momenti magici della vita e
dello sport andò tutto benissimo
piove dal primo all'ultimo metro ma non
cambierei una goccia di quel ricordo
vinsi con un buon margine
tutti i mattoncini si misero posto in
quello che è stato uno dei momenti più
belli della mia carriera
però poi quando vinci pensi meno forse
quello il rischio perché tutto va
perfettamente ed è lo sport ed è nella
vita si vince si perde si cade ci si
rialza
lo sport ha un potenziale potentissimo
nei miei 25 anni
in realtà di corse ho avuto la
possibilità di conoscere tanti tante
sfumature tante emozioni dello sport è a
fine carriera ho avuto la fortuna di
fare un incontro perché come si può
lasciare un grande amore come si può
lasciare una passione e così nel 2009
incontro libera libera di don luigi
ciotti e fortunatamente riusciamo a
capire come indirizzare tutta questa mia
esperienza sportiva e anche di altri
compagni di viaggio per cercare di
trovare una strada per crescere per
formare le coscienze civili dei ragazzi
perché lo sport può anche questo perché
lo sport educa a fratella perché lo
sport non amori perché lo sport
costruisce ponti perché lo sport ti fa
riconoscere l'altro
e allora decidiamo di organizzare una
serie di percorsi educativi attraverso
lo sport
libera è una rete di associazioni che si
sono messe insieme per cercare di
costruire un paese molto più libero
dalla prepotenza mafiosa dalla
corruzione dall'illegalità e ognuno deve
fare il suo pezzetto di strada e così
abbiamo organizzato delle staffette
stanno scorrendo le immagini di ragazzi
che corrono nei terreni confiscati alle
mafie terreni sottratti alla violenza
criminale restituiti alla collettività
con tanti ragazzi che ci corrono sopra
il senso proprio massimo della libertà
questo anche può fare lo sport il senso
del noi perché ogni ragazzo corre
cammina sata non è importante il ritmo i
nostri percorsi educativi attraverso lo
sport sono a di fuori di ogni logica di
agonismo e il senso di stare insieme è
il senso di contribuire ognuno per come
può a a un viaggio e vedete che tra le
mani i ragazzi e le ragazze hanno un
pezzo di legno
quello è un testimone è un testimone
speciale ne abbiamo dato una papà
francesco nel 2014 è un pezzo di legno
che abbiamo preso a lampedusa il pezzo
di legno
di una barca una barca che racconta la
storia di donne uomini bambini che
attraverso il nostro mar mediterraneo
arrivano sulle nostre coste provano ad
arrivare sulle nostre coste cercando una
vita migliore
noi abbiamo deciso di portarlo con quel
testimone che racconta una storia parla
di tanti e donne e uomini di cui non
sappiamo il nome gli invisibili del
mediterraneo abbiamo deciso di farli
correre con noi con i ragazzi per fare
memoria per sensibilizzare le nostre
coscienze
è un viaggio un viaggio che ci
responsabilizza tutti
ecco queste questa è stata un po la mia
vi rema vita come atleta professionista
e con libero ho avuto il privilegio di
poter riappropriarmi della bellezza
della solidarietà del senso di
fratellanza di di inclusione sociale di
una società che corre insieme nella
costruzione di un paese che ha voglia di
sentirsi una squadra credo che vale
nello sport come nella vita quei famosi
cinque secondi quel metro da percorrere
io ho cercato con le mie inquietudini
con i miei limiti perché lo sport
insegna a conoscere il tuo limite a
lavorare a sfidarlo ma anche ad
accettarlo
ho provato a cercare sempre di andare un
pochino oltre per vedere le cose da più
punti di vista e credo che nella vita lo
sport lo insegna
nonostante ci siano dei momenti di
scoramento di difficoltà soprattutto
quello che stiamo vivendo in questo
momento storico
pazzesco dove dobbiamo trovare dentro di
noi le energie mentali per cercare di
affrontare la complessità mondiale che
stiamo vivendo
credo che valga la pena e lo sport ce lo
insegna di portarselo anche nella vita
in certi momenti quando sentiamo che
forse non ce la facciamo più di provare
resistere ancora cinque secondi di
provare a tenere duro ancora per un
metro e magari questo può fare tutta la
differenza
grazie